[Music]
what do the Exorcist stand by me
blockers and big little lies have in
common a vomit scene for every
disgusting vomit scene in a movie
there's an effects team that actually
had to make the stuff and an actor who
had to sell it
hi everyone my name is Ben today I'm
heading to NYSP FX in Red Hook Brooklyn
and I'm gonna see how fake puke is made
for movies and TV and I couldn't be more
excited because I'm gonna get to try
some of it myself grab a snack mmm you
might not want to eat while you watch
this this is Mike Myers a
special-effects artist and the founder
of NYSP FX Myers and his team created
some of the coolest practical effects
for the Batman prequel show Gotham and
can do everything from breakaway glass
to fake blood but today is all about the
puke which Myers executed flawlessly in
the 2015 film while we're young watch
the carpet
fake vomit comes in all shapes sizes and
textures it can be made to look
realistic or exaggerated depending on
the scene and genre and while we're
young they used a combination of potato
leek and split pea soup we're attempting
today Top Ramen to give that squiggly
and soft noodle projectile nastiness to
hopefully stick to someone's lip when
they're done today we have some frozen
berries that we're gonna mix up color we
have tomato paste for that displaced
howl apparently look how good that looks
this looks very familiar to me we're not
too familiar for this experiment we use
three different types of puke so we got
our first fake puke right there that's
peas and water and then this was a nice
mix of ramen water and tomato paste and
so now we've got berries right third one
is gonna have berries and water great
this is definitely the kind of fake
vomit that's gonna stain my clothing
what I anticipated that so I wore my my
jeans that have to have pizza on them
already so once we had the mixtures it
was time to load them into the tubes now
this stage is actually just as important
to making convincing fake puke as the
actor who has to sell the scene the
pumps that we utilize are made for
liquids not vomit thick pasty substances
we use our main liquid as our propellant
and then in the vertical tubes on the
pumping incorporate the thicker paste
that will then be pushed upward and
outward first the mixture also needed to
be this texture for another reason
realism the medium density thick part of
the mixture will be fed into the top of
the tubes and the rest that comes out
will be more like liquid which Myers
says follows the pattern of real-life
vomit yeah that looks really gross I
needed a little acting advice first when
they have to like regurgitate and and
project there does have to be some body
motion involved but it pretty much has
to say if there's my hose and a mom
regurgitating I can't go up because then
my hose is coming out of my mouth so he
has to know to only go forward and open
his mouth wide and keep his mouth open
because if he's closed his mouth and the
vomit is still coming out what a wasted
take that is okay we're gonna we're
gonna do this whole bucket yeah that's
about eight gallon this is probably the
chunky astir and there was going to be a
lot of it
another one three-two-one 102 i think
getting the timing right is like the
first initial challenge you hear it
coming up and so like as long as you're
just kind of like you know ready to go
then then you're good to go the pea soup
mixture is different for several reasons
it's mixed with a lot of water making it
a lot more liquidy and for this they
instead use a pressure pot with clear
tubes attached
unlike the guy in the group project that
doesn't help but still gets an a anyways
great this hose allows you the
flexibility where you're not rigid okay
so because you have a guy behind you can
go left right up down turn to that
camera and splash you do want me to puke
on ya here you puke once we shut it off
it'll dribble dribble dribble great oh
and that gives some authentication
because it's also got a deflector in the
front that's gonna spray this works well
for a scene involving out-of-control
vomiting I want to watch out Nick one
piece of advice I would give
aim away from the camera I am covered in
fake puke and I'm not the only one for
some types of puke no rigs or hoses are
required
[Music]
a Facebook and reality it's for a
spit-take a member of the effects team
would scoop a little bit of fake puke up
that seems like a lot the actor would
then take some into their mouth and spit
it up like that how did that look guys
which I do some more actually really
good there's always room for a little
improvement there any tips you can give
me for how to improve my performance
well a good thing to do with just a
little more retching hello shoulder
movement and a little try to sell it a
little more and even if put your hand in
front and get a little bit more you know
separate where it's coming from maybe a
little bit coming down on yourself
alright no problem
yes I felt like I was in the most
control I could kind of obviously I
could time it myself I didn't have to to
time it up with with the rig or anything
like that which I think allowed me to
get more into my performance love varies
so that spit-take is is the one for me
and with no tubes to cover up nor
massive sprays to avoid the camera can
look straight on to the actor however
there are many ways to hide these pesky
tubes sometimes they're simply taken out
in post-production other times it's all
about where you place the camera and
while CGI is used to aid the process
fake vomit scenes are still largely done
practically more work than you can
imagine goes into creating something
that in the end might just be on screen
for a couple of seconds but can still be
the most memorable moment of any given
movie or TV show well it could be cool
if these are gets stained with very
juice then it might actually be kind of
a cool look the varies are delicious